so Matthew I think it's time we dealt
with your psychosis head-on you have one
of the most aggressive cases of multiple
personality disorder I have ever
encountered I'm sorry what do you I came
here for a mild depression yes and your
main persona the one we both know is
Matthew is the one who's mildly
depressed but he's one of many what that
this is ridiculous
Oh Chad what Chad the personality of
yours that doesn't think he has multiple
personalities hello Chad I'm not Chad
there he is
what No this is preposterous Oh Phil
Phil you're angry personality what a
grump
calm down Phil okay I'm not Phil I'm not
Chad I am Matt and yes I am angry
because you're not listening to me
Sheila your lady personality you always
think I'm not listening to you but I am
baby I'm listening tell me about your
day who Frank Frank the mute no I'm not
mute Frankie this is a big breakthrough
for you
what Leroy the confused one how you been
Leroy confused as ever no no no mojo the
pirate who's always saying no this is
messed up Janet the [ __ ] how's it going
Janet stay out of this all right
I'm not Janet the [ __ ] what a Janet
thing to say right how about this I'm
not paying for this
Oh Polly the guy who doesn't understand
I already have your credit card
information you you you know worse Jim
it go to your corner and stay there no
one likes a [ __ ] you know what that's
our time here's your bill mr. Matthew
Leroy I hope that doesn't confuse you
mojo there be your bill me no I'm not
paying for these what are you kidding me
God Janet don't throw envelopes you
salty [ __ ] I would totally Janet
you